our second so let's welcome the team so
far okay so often if you go into a
classroom you'll see a student and they
feel miss a different teacher and you
look at your class and they all say Amen
it can get really hard to be excited to
teach them and students feel this way
because they can't see the connections
between what they're studying and the
real world and we want to change that so
that instead they say things like Oh or
aha and that's so cool so how do we do
this how do we bring that passion we are
proposing a launch space which is a
hands-on space where teachers and
students can work collaboratively on
real-world projects and they'll be
really engaged and they'll want to learn
and so what does this face look like it
kind of breeds creativity so you have
tables where you can sit around and have
discussions and conversations and
whiteboards and supplies for aviation
and then you have the tools that you can
build and bring your ideas to life so
students will be coming with their teams
and they'll be really excited because
they're working on projects that relate
to the real world whether through the
community or through industry so instead
of a traditional teacher-student model
this space is going to have a
facilitator and this is someone who's
trained in creating a out-of-the-box
thinking design atmosphere and so
because there's a facilitator who will
draw from the community from industry
and eventually train teachers well the
teachers will check their identity at
the door they're going to become mentors
and work with their students on team
projects and they are working together
towards the same goal and these are
projects that are decided upon
collaboratively between a student and
the teacher because this make sure that
a the students are interested because
they're the ones who propose these
things and be the teachers also make
sure that they accomplish learning goals
that they set out at the beginning so
that these projects will complement what
they're learning in the regular classes
and so deliverables there of course be
self and peer review but also very
important is to have industry critiques
people from industry from outside
communities coming in and
taking them and this gives them
accountability and also expands their
worldview first question for me is is
this built into the schools or is this a
community program is this how the
community is this is a space that we're
going to put into the school with it's
all I got extra portable full of all the
cool all the cool stuff yes a portable
like like an actual portable a tools by
the trailers and the park outside
describe another track these projects so
it could be adaptable to each act so you
should behave almost like a design space
create without talking like we did over
here and then you have machines another
type into it but more long-term their
truck it's yeah this belongs use by the
owner yeah the mobile yet this is like
their design schools who pays for it so
because we're going to be working with
community industry we think they will be
interested because they have problems
that they propose who's a industry yeah
industry community but we think this is
a really cool idea to make the
connection between the concept that you
learn in the class and brick and apply
to the real world if it's a really good
idea after given the parents or the town
should be able to say okay this is
something very difficult exam
so cost shared with partners industry
partners University posters how does it
how do you imagine it interfaces with
what there's normally doing in school
you take it block of classes they're
gonna make the learning goals that they
have in their current classes and
they'll adapt it to the projects are
working on there will be a continuation
and a better way to think about what
they're learning in their normal huh and
as it involves they can use these
projects to then go back and figure out
what is the best way I can make this
project happen fifth more applicable
right leg as this goes on teachers can
like bring things oh yeah I can like
teach this part of the trick you up in
there and so they can adapt what they're
teaching in their classroom also is kind
of like a feedback